Good morning John,
let's go to the warehouse to get my Pizzamas stuff!
[Instrumental music]
The team at DFTDA has been working their butts off
for months getting ready for this
I cannot believe they pulled
some of these things off
When a Pizza John Chia Pet was
proposed to me, I said
that's a fun idea y 'all,
but we're not going to be able to make it happen
And yet!
It is a very pretty day in Missoula, Montana
If they could all be like this, everybody would live here
[beep beeps]
Just kidding
[Instrumental music]
And now I've got my box!
It's just a lot of enthusiasm
for Pizza John, John
It never... it does not decrease!
Now I have Pizza John stuff,
it's time to go home and give myself a mustache!
Going bald and then having your hair grow back
and suddenly getting facial hair
Seeing my, my face in the mirror in a
bunch of different ways like I'm a totally different person
I saw a comment on TikTok that said,
and Green went from,
uh... from enthusiastic TA to
grizzled tenured professor
in two months!
and yeah, I feel that
It's just made me very confident
in a way that like,
I'm not, like, I don't have to
be like a way
I looked one way for so long
I've had some looks over the years,
some of them I don't feel great about
Like that while I mix it up!
I had a Mohawk for a little while
and now I'm going to have a mustache!
How is that going to go?
There's no way to know!
I can't believe I'm saying
goodbye to my first beard
[Instrumental music]
That's goatee me
This is what goatee Hank looks like now
Ah, I think he looks fine
Who is that guy? Who is that guy?
That's a different guy!
Freakin' Walter White over here
I think I may be the one who knocks!
[Instrumental music]
I suppose that's a look
It's a look that some people could have
I'm excited to not have it honestly
There was so much hair
[music]
I feel like we found ourselves at
sort of a classic pizza John here
Uh, where the mustache keeps
going down for a little while
just like peak ridiculousness, but
I think I'm gonna clean mine up
I think that's yours John,
but what's mine?
Ahhhhh!
Hank: Good?
Katherine: Oh yeah, I mean it's a look
Oh, yeah!
[music]
Happy Pizzamas, John
from whoever the heck this guy is
I'm looking at him right now...
I don't know?
He's that guy!
He's me!
What's me?
John, I'll see you tomorrow